this is what a warming planet looks like
in reality pakistan on the front line of
the climate disaster
the flooding here is on an epic scale
with streets turned into rivers
and entire districts submerged by the
unending cycle of monsoon rains
our helicopters are having trouble
finding dry land in the south in
balochistan for instance
as to where to drop goods there are many
harrowing and heartbreaking scenes of
trauma and distress this is a huge
humanitarian disaster and i i would call
it
quite apocalyptic
the country's scientists say there's
been a massive change in the intensity
of the rainy season
with double the amount of water falling
in the last eight weeks
with rivers swollen and bursting their
banks
melting glaciers are also worse near
catastrophe that's killed more than a
thousand people
[Music]
many millions have been displaced
they're now living in makeshift camps
with basic provisions in short supply
people are the deprived house are living
in the very bad conditions facing very
troubled troublesome conditions such as
they are nowadays living in open areas
in some places the waters are slowly
receding but what's left is
heartbreaking the damage is overwhelming
in many areas
rehan ali and his family are trying to
salvage what they can
like countless others in this worsening
environmental disaster
he doesn't know how he will cope
i don't know how to rebuild my destroyed
house even i don't have anything to feed
my family i lost everything i don't know
where to go god help me
it is staggering almost beyond
comprehension that nearly a third of
pakistan is now underwater
that's an area the size of britain
and the monsoon isn't over yet with more
rain forecast
the authorities here are appealing for
urgent international assistance
but for many trapped by the rising flood
water
it may already be too late
alex rossi sky news